[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL CIRULI: They taught
me to tell you what you're
going to learn today first.
And so that's the first
thing I'm going to say.
And you're going to
learn two things.
And if there's two
takeaways from today
besides how to be an
awesome SRE like Nori,
those two things
are, first, Istio
and a bunch of the other things
we're developing at Google,
give you the tools
that you need to start
SRE-ing like Google SREs.
And second-- it's working now.
NORI HEIKKINEN:
And second, Dan's
going to tell you all about
what Istio actually is.
DANIEL CIRULI: You've
probably heard this word a lot
in this conference.
And probably-- how many
people had never heard
the word "Istio" before they
came to Google Cloud Next?
A chunk of you.
We're going to make sure
that you know what that is.
But first of all, who are we?
NORI HEIKKINEN: So as I
mentioned, my name is Nori.
I've been at Google for 13
years and SRE for 10 of that.
During my time in SRE,
I've worked basically
exclusively on infrastructure.
My first team at Google--
my first SRE team at Google
worked on the
infrastructure powering,
basically, all of the
services that Google provides.
All the DNS, all
the load balancing,
DOS protection, and
stuff like that.
And in the last two
years, I've been
working on a team
that is responsible
for the infrastructure
powering Google Cloud.
My team manages-- is
responsible for the production
health of App Engine
Flexible Environment and GKE.
And what I always like to
say about the teams I work on
is the y-axis of our
graphs is pretty nice.
DANIEL CIRULI: My
name is Dan Ciruli,
and I am a product manager.
I've been at Google
for about five years,
and I've spent that entire time
working on Google's own APIs
and Services Infrastructure,
the stuff that
serves the Maps APIs, the
Drive APIs, the YouTube APIs,
and, of course,
all the Cloud APIs.
And for the last
couple of years,
we've been focused on
productizing that technology.
And that's in the form of
some commercial products,
like Google Cloud End Points.
And most recently, open source
efforts like GRPC and Istio.
NORI HEIKKINEN: So,
SRE, as I'm sure you're
aware because you're here,
stands for Site Reliability
Engineering.
And we call it Site
Reliability Engineering,
it's a term that Google made up,
because many years ago Google
was just a website.
And these days it's a
little more than that,
but the term has stuck around.
In the beginning,
when it was just
a group of software engineers
working on web search,
they set up alerting,
they set up monitoring,
as I'm going to tell you all
about in a few brief slides.
And they sent their alerting
targets to page everyone
all at the same time
when there was a problem.
And they found that a few people
were always the same ones who
were responding to alerts.
And those people eventually
sort of gravitated
into the role that became SRE.
And they-- what I like
about this role is,
it's more of-- it's still
operationally driven.
We still get paged and we
have to fix the problems.
But it is at its basis
an engineering role.
So instead of taking
your classic ops role
from a generation ago
where you get paged to 2:00
in the morning, you don't
know what's happening,
you have to fix the proximate
cause, but that's about all
you could do.
In SRE, we do get paged, ideally
not at 2:00 in the morning.
We have pretty good two-site
SRE team distribution.
But you still, you fix
the proximate cause.
You always mitigate first.
But then, you do
root cause analysis
or a blameless postmortem.
You understand what
really happened
and what drove you
to this situation.
And then you-- and it's
not only an option,
but it's in fact your
job to fix the problem so
that the same thing
never happens again.
And that's why I like it.
It's really got the
balance of both of those.
SRE has learned a lot
during the last decade,
in fact, more than a decade.
Initially, that was how
to run systems at scale,
power a Google web search,
and then all of the apps
that run on the
similar infrastructure
inside of Google.
But more recently,
we've been learning
how to leverage that
knowledge and bring it,
not only to Google Cloud,
but also into the open source
community.
This is a book that our
department collectively wrote.
It describes many
SRE best practices.
And I'm onstage with Dan right
now because Istio actually
enables you to implement many
of these best practices straight
out of the box.
DANIEL CIRULI: By the way,
I don't know if any of you
have been in any sessions
today that use the Dory.
The Dory is a Q&A tool that
we use internally at Google.
And as an experiment,
we're letting
you guys use it here today.
So if you do come up with any
questions during the course
of the talk, if you
open up the Next 18 app
and go to this session,
you'll see a little link
that says Dory Q&A.
It lets you enter
a question and also
lets you vote on questions.
So it ensures that if there's
something everybody is dying
to ask, but no one gets
up to the microphone,
you can up-vote questions.
So whether you're submitting
questions or just voting,
please feel free
to use that tool.
NORI HEIKKINEN: And I'm also
told to mention on that one
that we are able to
go back after the talk
and respond to these
questions that we may not
have gotten a chance to answer
during the session in the tool.
You'll have to go
back into the tool
to view that, we can't
send email notifications.
But you'll be able to see
some more answers there later.
DANIEL CIRULI: So, I do want to
start by talking about Istio.
What is this Istio,
and why is everybody
talking about it so much?
We're getting a lot of N
plus 1 redundancy here.
That's apparently not--
NORI HEIKKINEN: Do
you want me to just--
DANIEL CIRULI: Yeah, please do.
Oh, hey.
[INAUDIBLE] You figure out
how to get to the next slide.
Maybe try the other thing.
So Istio is a service mesh.
And you're probably
hearing this term
if you look at the Google
Trends on service mesh,
it is an area of big interest
and increasing interest.
And I want to describe a service
mesh in a few number of words.
The important things
about a service mesh
is that it automates
away a lot of the things
that we typically build on
top of our network stacks.
Automates away
things like seeing
what's going on in terms of
traffic to your services,
providing authentication and
authorization on top of those.
So it does that, but
very importantly,
to be considered a
service mesh, you
have to do that in
a transparent way.
A service mesh isn't something
you code to, necessarily.
In fact, most developers should
never even know it's there.
It has to be something
that can layer
in on top of whatever
you're already doing.
Whatever language
you're already using,
whatever platform you
like to deploy on.
The idea of a service
mesh is to automate
a lot of the functionality out
of the network, up-level what
the network gives
you in a completely
transparent and
language-independent way.
And Istio is not
just a service mesh
but it's an open
services platform.
There are a few
different service
meshes that have come out
in the last couple of years.
And where Istio differentiates
is by defining a set of APIs
that make it easy to integrate
back-end systems as well.
So arbitrary, you log
wherever you want to,
you monitor wherever
you want to,
you use whatever arbitrary
policy engines you want to.
And again, all your services
are taking advantage of that
without coding themselves,
without integrating
into the service
mesh explicitly.
We talk about it a lot in
the context of Kubernetes,
but Istio is not dependent
on-- it's not dependent
that you only deploy
workloads in Kubernetes.
We do have people who are
deploying workloads across VMs
as well.
So what does it do?
What is the functionality
that it offers you once you
layer in this
transparent service mesh?
The first thing
is observability.
It's kind of unbelievable
how many people out
there are deploying
apps into Kubernetes
and have no idea what's going
on in those applications.
It gives you good
visibility into what's
happening in a
distributed application.
The second thing, it
says operational agility.
And by operational
agility what I mean
is being able to control
where a request goes.
And be able to have
a safe and sane way
to roll out new versions of
services as you're doing that.
And be able to
control, hey, maybe we
need to send traffic
to a different region
right now because this one
is very busy and overloaded.
And then the third major
area of functionality
is security, is allowing you to
secure traffic between services
and ensuring that, now that
your application has gone
from being a monolith
to being composed
of, say, 100 separate
services, how
do you ensure that each
of those is secure?
So three big things for Istio--
observability,
agility, and security.
How does it do that?
I won't go through
all the components,
but I will tell you
that the key here
is through the use
of a sidecar proxy.
Sidecar proxy is simply a
proxy that gets deployed
alongside your application.
If you're doing
this in a VM, you've
got to make sure that that
proxy gets installed on the VM.
But if you're using
Kubernetes, Kubernetes
has great features that allow
that to happen transparently.
So whenever you
deploy a pod, you
put whatever you want
in your containers,
Kubernetes can automatically
deploy the sidecar
alongside your pod.
And all traffic into
and out of your service
goes through that--
goes through that proxy.
And that means it can
make smart decisions
about how to route that call.
And we'll get into some details
later about what that means.
But also as a call comes
in, can make decisions about
whether or not that call
should be allowed in.
And it does all that,
again, transparently.
Your services can be
communicating via whatever
protocol they want.
HTTP for most of you.
GRPC for some of you.
Could be just a TCP connection.
It doesn't matter to us.
All the traffic goes in and out,
and by interposing that proxy
in there, we get to add
in some functionality.
This project is something that
we started about 18 months ago,
and we have been working with
some partners the whole time.
IBM and Lyft both started from
the very beginning with us.
We use Lyft's envoy proxy.
Super, super performant,
small footprint proxy
that we really like and is
really getting great adoption
across the industry.
But we're also working with
a bunch of other pretty heavy
hitters in the industry.
Red Hat is working on this.
VMware has done a
bunch of work on it.
We're working with Cisco.
And so we're really not--
we're really trying to
get a consortium of people
from around the
industry to say, hey,
this is a good way to do this.
This is a good way to
solve this problem.
And we're getting as many
companies as we can behind it.
NORI HEIKKINEN:
So the first point
Dan mentioned a couple of
slides ago was observability.
So I'm going to give
you a little background
about observability
best practices
and then how we've
implemented those at Google.
So the first thing is
observability begins
with monitoring.
Now, I admit that calling
monitoring an SRE best practice
is a bit of an exaggeration.
It's very fundamental.
A brief story about this.
So when Mikey Dickerson,
who's a former Google SRE,
went out to DC as
part of the tech surge
to help fix healthcare.gov
a few years ago,
he found that they
had no monitoring.
Well, correction, they actually
did have a very basic form
of monitoring, it
was a TV on the wall
and it was playing CNN.
And whenever CNN reported--
this is no joke--
whenever CNN reported that
healthcare.gov was down,
they knew they had a problem.
They should probably go fix it.
[LAUGHTER]
DANIEL CIRULI: Anyone
else use CNN as a service?
They're the only ones?
[LAUGHTER]
NORI HEIKKINEN: I'll
tell you how to fix that.
Mikey, perhaps, got
a little exasperated
and drew them a
hierarchy of needs.
He called it a
"reliability hierarchy."
And this has become known
as the Dickerson Hierarchy
of Reliability since then.
Modeled, of course,
after Maslow's Hierarchy
of Needs of physiological
safety first
and then on up through
friendship and things
like that.
In the Dickerson
Hierarchy of Reliability,
you have monitoring
right at the bottom
because having CNN on the
wall is not an acceptable form
of monitoring.
And so in this pyramid that
I'm going to show right now,
I've sort of extrapolated
monitoring out
into its own pyramid with
its sub building blocks.
What should you monitor?
At Google and over the course of
developing many best practices
over the years, we've
decided that we have
at least four golden signals.
And these are four
things that if you
monitor it will give you a
really good, basic insight
into how your system is doing.
And they are, in
this order, traffic.
How many requests are
coming into your system?
This is commonly known as
RPS, Requests Per Second.
At Google, we still call them
QPS for most of our systems
because every request is
a web search query, right?
That sort of stuck around.
But this is your
building block here
is, how much traffic
are you serving?
Beyond this is errors.
Of that traffic
that you're serving,
are you serving it successfully?
Are you serving any
of it successfully?
Are you saying all
You need to be monitoring
not only the requests that
come into your system but
also the percentage of them
that fail.
And I do mean percentage.
You have to start with traffic,
so you have a denominator here.
But if you know that you
have 1,000 errors per second
that you're serving, that's
probably a bad thing.
But if 1,000 requests
per second, or QPS,
is actually 0.001% of
your overall traffic,
that might be an acceptable-ish
amount of errors.
So, this is a rate here.
The next one is latency.
And we'll find that, as
we go up this pyramid,
we're sort of moving out of
the realm of, we need oxygen
and we need water.
And more into things
like, we need friendship.
And latency is a
really good sort
of friendship analogy in
this monitoring pyramid here.
Latency is not
quite as fundamental
as traffic and
errors, but you still
do need to be monitoring
latency to understand
the overall performance
of your system.
Users expect apps to be
super fast these days.
And in this highly
networked world,
most of that budget
for latency is
going to come out of your code.
And so you do want to
be measuring latency.
An interesting note on
how to do this here.
Don't just do this as
a straight average.
Latency, if you took the average
of all the latency of all
of the requests coming into
and out of your system,
you would end up [INAUDIBLE]
some important points.
You wouldn't get a sense of
what the common experience
of your app is because you
might have some requests way out
at your long tail, which
for various reasons,
might be taking a very
long time to complete.
And these could be for
legitimate reasons or reasons
that you want to look
into a little more deeply.
But either way, it's really
good to break that out.
And so when we talk about
monitoring latency at Google,
we talk about it in terms
of, generally, three numbers.
We talk about the
50th percentile,
or the median latency.
We often refer to that as P50.
And then the 90th
percentile, P90.
And then P99 as well.
And taking those three
lines as separate,
you usually see them--
P50 is pretty steady
state for your system.
P90 is probably
generally a little higher
but should still be within
the realm of normal.
And P99 is a really interesting
signal to split out here.
So, I think that's just
an important concept
to mention that latency
as an average is not
going to get you very far.
And finally, saturation.
This is a metric
that is even fuzzier,
and this one is up to you
to define a little more
than the other three.
Saturation is the idea of, at
what point is your service just
going to fall over?
If you had no load
shedding, no auto scaling
enabled, nothing like that.
You need to know about the
capacity of your service.
This could be as simple
as CPU utilization.
It's a very common saturation
metric out of the box.
But it also might be that,
based on your knowledge
of your own system,
it's actually
a much more complicated
metric that you calculate
and that you can export a
variable based on this one.
But what you want to
do with saturation
is feed that into
things I mentioned,
such as auto scaling.
And it can be a signal to
tell the system that it's time
to auto scale up
and add more tasks.
It can be a signal
to load shedding.
To say that the system is full,
we can't auto scale any more,
and we want to start
dropping queries.
It could just be a white
box signal to page a human
and say, please
come add more jobs.
We're about to fall over, the
system is almost at capacity.
But no matter how
you treat it, these--
saturation is the fourth
of these golden signals
that, taken together, form a
pretty good idea of the health
of your overall system.
So in the old days at Google,
whenever a new service
wanted to launch,
they would have
to basically write their
own monitoring from scratch.
And it wasn't quite
as dire as that.
I mean, there was
a standard library.
Each service would include
the standard library
and then export a standard
set of variables, requests
for seconds, errors, et cetera.
But then, the manual part was
that each new service owner
had to manually aggregate
these and define the monitoring
configuration to
aggregate these all up.
And then define, what were the
dashboards going to look like.
It was a very tedious process.
Trust me, I did it once.
I've got the badge
to prove it, but I
don't want to do it again.
And so what's cool these days is
that when new services launch,
or really when you turn up
any job in our production
environment, you get
this for free these days.
Now we use a sidecar proxy.
And the sidecar proxy is
automatically collecting
the metrics that I mentioned.
It's collecting the golden
signals and a fair number
of other ones besides.
And it automatically puts
these into a dashboard for you.
So these days, when we have
this automatic aggregation--
this is a screenshot of the
dashboard that you'll see.
We just picked an arbitrary
small service here.
But you can see that these are
three basic graphs that just
list out the golden signals.
This-- no work was done on
the part of the service owner
to get these graphs.
This is observability for free.
And this has been an incredibly
powerful concept at Google.
Not only does it remove the
need for each individual service
owner to redefine their
monitoring from scratch,
but it also means
that, when you want
to look into the performance
of somebody else's system
within our organization,
you can do that.
And so in many cases--
again, in the old days, we would
maintain these lists of links
to the various
monitoring dashboards
and these other
services, and you
hope that then you
remember to find
where your page of
aggregated links is.
And that nobody else moved their
dashboards or they're not down.
It was a bit of a nightmare.
And these days, if you
have a service that
has a dependency on
some other service,
you suspect the
dependency may be
at fault in some issue
you're currently debugging,
you don't have to find
your bookmarked link.
You can just go to our
central automatic monitoring
dashboard, type in
their service name,
and view their dashboards.
It's so cool.
Of course, these other
services can go in and tweak
these metrics themselves.
They can make custom dashboards.
They can make it prettier.
But what you're seeing here is
that out of the box, at Google,
you just get
dashboards for free.
These are a couple of
zoom-in dashboards here.
This is the top one you see,
this says requests in errors.
There's three lines on here
and so you-- we actually
almost always will graph
the request per second
against errors per
second there in two types
of errors in this one.
We also have the
internal error ratio,
which is the second piece
of that monitoring pyramid.
And latency.
Again, you'll notice
on the latency graph,
there's those three lines.
And the red one is P50 latency.
Pretty normal
realm for that one.
The next one up is P90 latency.
And that's still within
the normal realm.
You can see in this particular
graph, it's about double
of what the P50 latency is.
That may or may not be expected
based on the performance
of your system.
But then P99 latency,
I think this perfectly
illustrates why it's really
important to split these out
into their own bands so you can
reason about them separately.
The other part of observability
as a complement to the metrics
and the dashboards, is logging.
When you're debugging an issue,
dashboards are a great start,
and often they'll tell
you what you need to know.
Sometimes you'll
see a steep drop-off
on the number of running
tasks or a steep uptick
in the number of queries per
second coming to your system.
Those are great places to start.
But occasionally, you'll get
into a really gnarly issue
where you need to dig
into exactly what happened
at a certain period of time.
At Google, our systems
generate huge volume of logs.
We're doing huge volume
of requests at all times.
We basically log everything.
We have reasonable
retention periods.
But for a finite
period of time, when
you're trying to understand
what happened in your system,
you can go back and
dig through these logs
to try to figure out, in
precise detail, what happened.
But the only reason
this works at all
is that we have tools to help
us slice and dice this data.
Petabytes of logs are useless
if all you have is grep.
[LAUGHTER]
And there was a groan.
Yeah, that's how I
feel about that one.
Dremel is our internal
SQL like interface
over these huge volumes of logs.
It lets us drill
down into what's
happening at the precise
moment we need it.
And it's a much
more powerful tool
than simply trying to open
these up in your editor
and muck around to
try to distill down.
I have been at Google long
enough that it turns out
that Dremel is such
a power tool for me
that it took me many years,
more than I'd like to admit,
of being an SRE before
somebody actually pointed out
to me that a dremel is
a real, physical thing.
[LAUGHTER]
DANIEL CIRULI: Great.
So thank you, Nori,
for that and explaining
what are these things that
we feel you need to have.
The tools in your
arsenal that you
need if you want to be an SRE.
And now I want to talk a little
bit about how Istio gives you
some of those tools.
Sure, I can drive, I suppose.
Didn't like me before.
Again, emphasizing what I
said about a service mesh.
You can get observability today.
All of you are doing
some monitoring.
No one is really
using CNN, right?
But what tends to happen
is, different teams
solve this in different ways.
And if you're
running operations,
depending on which team
developed a service,
you might have a
different set of metrics.
Some things might be
gathered from logs.
Other people are somehow
sending telemetry somewhere.
Other things they would
like to use the same metrics
that that team has,
but they're developing
in a different language
and the client library just
doesn't work as well in Node
as it does in Java, say.
So with Istio, we want to
give a standard set of metrics
without doing any integration.
Without language specific
client libraries.
And out of the box, we give
you most of the golden signals.
Traffic, errors, and latency.
The things that Nori said, you
can't really run a service well
without these metrics.
We give you that out of the box.
So every service that you're
deploying into your service
mesh, you get that
out of the box.
Now, as she said, saturation
is different for every service.
In some cases, it might be CPU.
In some cases, it might be RAM.
Other ones, it might be a number
of operations going to disk.
You'll have to figure
that out for your service.
But for most of these, out
of the box, we'll gather them
and we'll send them to the
location of your choosing.
And to do that we use
a component in Istio
called Mixer.
Mixer is a runtime component
we deploy into your Kubernetes
cluster.
And it has a very
pluggable architecture.
All of these sidecar
proxies, when
they receive requests,
when they return requests,
they are sending all
this telemetry to Mixer.
Mixer, then, can plug into
the system of your choice.
Maybe you're using Prometheus.
Maybe you just run an Influx DB.
Maybe you're using
external vendors.
People are writing
these already,
and certainly we
have a fantastic one
for our Stackdriver tool.
Mixer is the component that--
we won't get into policy today,
but in addition to
enforcing policy,
it also gathers all the
telemetry and sends it out.
And of course, we
think a great place
to send this is Stackdriver.
This is in Alpha in
Stackdriver today,
and it's a fantastic
view into not just
what's going on with
a particular service,
but how these services
are interoperating.
This is a dependency graph,
and it builds this graph
depending on the actual traffic
observed in your system.
This is a really big deal.
When someone joins
your team tomorrow,
I guarantee you someone is
going to go to a whiteboard
and draw a picture of what
all your services are.
And I can also guarantee,
it's probably wrong.
[LAUGHTER]
I know this from when
we got this at Google.
People don't know
their dependencies.
They don't know who's
dependent on them.
This actually knows,
and it can tell you.
And it can tell you not just
how much traffic you're getting,
but how much traffic you're
getting from each client.
When things are
running slowly, this
can help you root
it out very quickly.
And as you can see
on the left there,
you get the golden signals
for every one of these.
You get your traffic,
you get your errors,
and you get your latency.
We collect all your logs, too.
And I sometimes talk to
customers and they ask,
what percentage of our
requests should be logged?
And the answer is easy,
it's a triple-digit number.
You log all your requests.
You don't have to
keep them forever.
But when something
goes wrong, you never
know which request was going
to make that thing go wrong.
And if you weren't
logging, you're in trouble.
But as Nori said, lots of logs
are difficult to deal with
and almost unusable unless
you have good tools.
Stackdriver logs.
It's got a great logs viewer.
But even better, you can
pipe it into BigQuery.
And in BigQuery, it's Dremel.
You can write great SQL
queries across those
logs to do analytics.
You can figure out what went
wrong in a particular event.
And you know, big
analytics things.
It's a really,
really powerful tool.
I didn't get into tracing,
but Istio's also gathering
tracing for you as well.
Now talk about SLIs.
NORI HEIKKINEN: So once you're
monitoring your service,
you can use these signals to
talk about health at a service
level.
And then also to
help you plan how
you're going to react
if those signals start
to dip a little bit.
There's lots of TLAs in this
space, please bear with me.
An SLI, this is
metrics, essentially.
This is, basically,
the golden signals
are a great place to start.
They are just a sense
of what's happening
in your system on a
quantifiable basis.
Also, I should note that
these are often the things
that you define your alerts on.
Alerting is something I could
give its own 50-minute talk
about.
But very briefly, if you
alert on the golden signals,
that's a great place to start.
SLO uses the SLIs.
These are targets
for these metrics.
They're either target
values or target ranges.
Pro tip here.
100% is not a good SLO.
Typical availability ranges are
measured in number of nines.
This is, again, very
service dependent.
It may be two nines, depending--
99%, depending on what your
service can reasonably achieve.
Or it might be five or six
nines, a very highly available
service.
But again, 100% is just
never going to happen.
One of the fundamental tenets
of engineering for reliability
is, you have to
plan for failure.
Things are going to break.
Machines are going to break.
VMs are going to break.
The network is going to go down.
There will be failures.
And so assuming, or just hoping
that they will never happen
is, as we say in
SRE, not a strategy.
So set a really high service--
service level objective.
But measure it in nines
and don't use 100% here.
An SLA is a legal agreement.
This is basically a
threshold after which
the-- you the customer
or your customers,
depending on which direction
you're talking about,
get remunerations
or other things
coming back to them in
breach of the contract.
So when we're talking
about reliability
from the engineering
standpoint, very often
internally we're
speaking of SLIs and SLOs
because those are the
things that we have
the most direct control over.
Choosing what to measure and
then choosing what thresholds
are actually achievable.
And we leave SLAs to the
more business and legal end
of the company.
Another way of saying
SLO is by, instead
of looking at the area
under that target threshold,
looking at the area above.
And that's your error budget.
I love this concept.
People can think of
it, and typically do,
very productively
as a constraint.
And I think that's
great, and I'll
talk through why I
like that in a minute.
But I think it's also
important to remember,
the flip side of that is that
it can be permissive as well.
So the constraint side.
This is the typical way to
think about an error budget.
You set your SLOs, you
monitor, you define alerts.
You have those alerts
paging humans or, you know,
maybe feeding back
into automated systems
to take action.
And then you take some sort
of action at the system level
to increase reliability
if you dip down
below your error budget.
Again, this could be
it's own 50-minute talk.
But very briefly,
a typical response
to going out of error
budget is to freeze.
Freezes are basically
the idea, if you
stop pushing change
live to your system,
change, be it in the
form of a new release
candidate of your binary or
binaries or, even more, config,
we recognize that
all of these things
are vectors of instability.
And so you need to
manage that instability.
Typically, the way you
do this is you just
stop pushing until you're
back within your error budget
to recover that.
And the idea here is twofold.
One, it gives your
customers or your users
a greater period of
stability because you just
experienced an outage, or maybe
a very slow trickle of outages,
and you'd like to have them have
overall a very good experience.
The other idea here
is that typically you
can redirect the
engineering effort that
would have been going into new
features into reliability work.
A flip side of this
is the way in which
an error budget is permissive.
As a former manager
of mine used to say,
what good are all those nines
if you can't take them out
for a spin every now and then?
[LAUGHTER]
But like, I did say it
jokingly and so did he,
but what I like about this
is it actually gives you
a good sense of when it is a
good time to take extra risks.
Is it a good time right before
your big annual conference?
Probably not.
But, if you're-- the week
after, if you are well within
your error budget and your
engineers have been asking
to try out a crazy new feature
that's very well tested
but does carry a
greater degree of risk,
you have a budget to spend.
That's why I like to
think of it as a budget.
DANIEL CIRULI: If
you've ever been waiting
for a new feature from
some Google product
and it seemed to get delayed
maybe a month later than you
wanted it, it may be that
that team ran out of budget.
And they weren't permitted
to launch that feature.
It really does affect
how we launch things.
So now I want to
talk a little bit
about one of the
very cool things that
isn't specific to Istio
alone, but it's something
that you get when you combine
Istio and Stackdriver.
And that's the
ability to define--
to monitor your SLIs
and define SLOs.
So I mentioned
this before, but we
are shipping today in open
source an adapter with Istio
to send your metrics
to Stackdriver.
That includes your traces,
it includes your logs,
but of course the telemetry,
the things that were powering
that graph I showed you before.
Well, they've got a
nifty new feature.
And their nifty new
feature is the ability
to set service level objectives.
And what's awesome
is because they're
getting the metrics
from your services,
you can now set SLOs,
Service Level Objectives,
on the golden signals.
It seems like an obvious thing,
but it's a fantastic thing.
I literally know customers
who alert because they
have their logs, they
scrape their logs,
they send their logs
to a third party vendor
where they can write a grep,
run that grep every say, 5 or 15
minutes, and then, if they have
too many errors, do an alert.
Who does something like that?
Some of you are not being
completely truthful.
I know that's happening.
[LAUGHTER]
It's really, really crit-- like,
you might as well turn on CNN.
This is the way you
should be doing this.
Have something that's
gathering your telemetry,
set an [INAUDIBLE].
And say, hey I want to make
sure that we are available,
that we're returning our
requests successfully.
Say, every week.
You might do it per month,
you might do it per quarter.
And say I want that to be at
a certain range, 91%, 92%.
Now you set this objective
within Stackdriver,
and Stackdriver will alert you
if you get out of compliance.
Now, you might not set
this where your SLA is.
If you're telling
your customers,
you know, 99.9, you might
set this a little bit higher
so that you get alerted
before your customer--
before you're out of compliance.
But then they will let you
monitor this, they'll show you,
here's how you're doing
against your goal.
And you can see sometimes I'm
above, sometimes I'm below.
But what's important, they'll
show you your budget as well.
In the aggregate, are we
doing OK, or are we not?
Are we positive,
or are we negative?
So it's a really fantastic tool.
It's taking some
very basic concepts.
If you've read the SRE book,
you will have read about this.
And you may have thought,
wow, error budgets sound cool.
How would I implement that?
The good news is
that they just did
and that you can take
advantage of this.
And now back to you.
NORI HEIKKINEN: So
another SRE best practice
is that of canary releases.
And we do it so much
we call it canarying.
So as I mentioned when I
was talking about freezes,
new releases commonly
cause instability.
So you need to manage
that instability.
Canary jobs are small jobs that
are basically identical to all
of the other workloads you
have running in production,
but they're configured
to get traffic early.
And they also, importantly,
take a very small fraction
of your traffic.
And so the same concept
applies as the canary
in the mine shaft.
You send the canary
down the mine shaft
first so that, if toxic fumes
have built up down there,
the canary keels over instead
of all of the mining team
all at once.
Same concept applies here.
If you send a binary down
into the mine shaft--
this analogy is breaking down--
and it falls over, you know
then to not immediately
continue your rollout to all
of production all at once,
creating a huge outage.
A couple points about how
to do canarying effectively.
One is you need to
monitor the canary.
Because this is, remember,
running a very small percentage
of your traffic-- it might
be 1% of your traffic,
it might be even less than that
depending on your service--
you need to monitor
it independently.
If you just fold it
into the monitoring
for your overall
service, the error
is coming forward, even
if the canary is loudly
cheeping in its
death throes, are
going to get folded
in to the rest
of your overall
aggregate alerting.
And very likely, you
won't hear about it.
So you need specific
alerting on your canary tasks
or your canary jobs.
And they need to be causing
somebody to take an action.
Either that's the automated
rollout server automatically
rolls back or a human hits
the pause button or something.
But either way, you
need to monitor these
independently so that you
can catch things early,
which is the whole point.
And the other thing is,
you need to pace yourself.
Your service may go
through peaks and valleys.
In web search, back in
the day, probably still,
we had a nice diurnal curve.
And your service may
have different traffic
characteristics.
Also depending on the
deployment of your service,
the various locations may
receive a different traffic
mix.
And so you ideally want to have
canary jobs in each region,
or in each place, or in
each configuration that
has a unique perspective
on your service just
to get the best signal you can.
And so you want to go
slowly here, whatever
that means for your service.
In the case of something
like web search,
you might choose to do a
one-day canary period just
to get the full diurnal
cycle and make sure
that your canary really
sees all kinds of traffic.
In something where you have
a much more aggressive CICD
on like an every
half hour basis,
the canary may only be
30 seconds or a minute
or something.
But this is something
that you are
going to want to define
to be meaningfully
slow for your service.
DANIEL CIRULI: Guess what?
Istio helps with that too.
I want to start by talking about
the problem with Kubernetes.
And by the way, and Nori
did say, Dan, are you sure
you want to title a slide
"The Problem with Kubernetes?"
And I laughed and I said yes.
Someone else said are you sure
you don't want to just call
it "A problem with Kubernetes?"
Because there might
be more than one.
But one problem
with Kubernetes is
that Kubernetes,
it load balances.
If you've got a workload
that's running at enough scale
that you need two
pods, it'll load
balance between those two pods.
So if you-- version one,
you're doing enough QPS
that it takes two to
satisfy that, it'll run two.
Well, say you've got a
new version of that binary
that you deploy.
What is Kubernetes going to do?
It'll bring up a new
version of that pod,
and it will get an equal
share of the traffic.
This is not a best
practice of Kubernetes.
If you need a 1%
rollout, you shouldn't
need to run 99 pods
of your other thing
in order to achieve
that 1% rollout.
But that's literally what
you would have to do,
and I've heard vendors talk
about things just like that.
That's not the right
way to do things.
And she said, you want to
start with something small.
1%, for us sometimes it's
a tenth of a percent.
And then you want
to go to, say, 10.
And then you want to
go to 20 or 50, right?
But you want to control
the pace of the rollout.
Not with the number of pods that
are running but with something
a little bit more explicit.
So we have a component
called Pilot.
And Pilot is a component
that pushes route rules
to the sidecar proxies.
And what this gives us is the
ability to do load balancing,
but importantly, it
enables us-- by the way,
this is also running an ingress.
So for traffic coming from--
in off the internet, it's also
going through an envoy proxy.
And Pilot can tell
your services,
whether they're the
ingress or whether it's
service-to-service
traffic, hey, there's
a new version of this
one, but you should only
send 1% of the traffic to that.
So it's easy.
YAML, and here you see it's
got some YAML that shows.
We've got V1, I want that
to get a weight of 90.
And I've got a V2, and I want
that to get a weight of 10.
So in Kubernetes, it's
still running three pods,
but they're not
getting equal shares.
Instead, that version 2 is
getting the 10% you want.
And of course, we are
gathering the metrics from it.
We're gathering the telemetry
so we can actually do
the thing that you really want.
Which is, you can look at your
telemetry for just that canary
and you can say, is this--
is it compliant?
Are the error ratios where
we expect them to be?
Are the latencies where
they're expected to be?
And if so, then we'll
go to that next phase.
Getting started with
Istio, we'd love for you
to get started with Istio.
As I said, we've been going
at it about 18 months.
We are very, very close
to declaring it 1.0.
That'll happen any day now.
We've done a lot of work.
This is not a
half-baked project.
We have-- over 200
developers have
contributed to the project.
We're very happy about that.
From a bunch of different
companies, as I said.
We've got it in production.
eBay was on stage, I
think, talking about it.
And sitting in the
front row here,
we have a few
different customers.
Auto Trader in the UK.
We've got people who are
doing hundreds of thousands
of requests a second.
We have people who are doing
more than 1,000 services.
These are all production
use cases I'm talking about.
We've got adapters for
many monitoring systems,
including, of
course, Stackdriver.
And what we announced-- what
Urs announced on stage yesterday
was managed Istio as part of our
coming Cloud Services Platform.
We are just about to go
into alpha on managed Istio.
And that's Istio automatically
installed, upgraded,
and supported in GKE.
So, you can get started soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]